so let's
let's okay dear colleagues it's a few
minutes past three o'clock we have a
very busy schedule
so I would like to open session of this
afternoon by welcoming you all to the
coffee committee and the first hearing
of 2023 so it's a little bit late but
it's still January so best wishes for
all of you
um and I think it will be an important
coming months
um because we um well we have to start
drafting the report and the Amendments
but we still have one pillar um of our
mandate to fulfill and that's what we
will start off um of today
the three hearings we will attend today
and tomorrow we'll look at the impact of
the pandemic on democracy and
fundamental rights and the hearing today
will specifically look at the impact of
this information misinformation and
propaganda on Democracy during the
pandemic and we'll come to that in just
a second
um if there are no comments uh the
agenda can be adopted and approval of
the minutes of the 28th and the 29th of
November and the 8th of December
um uh of 2022. I have three
announcements to make to you the first
is I hope you've all seen it but let me
do it officially at the meeting of the
18th of January 2023 the conference of
presidents endorsed the request of the
three-month extension of the committee's
term of office and that will mean since
we started officially at the 19th 19th
April of 2022 the committee's extension
of turnovers Office is done until the
19th of July of 2023 and I think that
was the agreement we make sure that we
conclude the reports by voting in
plenary before the summer break
second announcements at the coffee
committee coordinators meeting on the
11th of January we have decided to
initiate action by a letter from the
chair to president metzola necessary for
the suspension or withdrawal of the
long-term access batches of Pfizer to
Parliament uh pursuing to rule one to
three of parliament's rules of procedure
this is a response to the coffee the
coffee committee deemed necessary to the
Pfizer's CEO Dr Bula rejecting to honor
two consecutive invitations to
participation in this coffee Committee
hearing
so the coordinators considered that so
far there was no answer given for
preliminary negotiations for the
procurement agreement for vaccines with
a particular emphasis on the third
contract with Pfizer and biontek
I've referred through a letter to
present to president metzola the matter
to the parliament's governing bodies and
Secretary General for a decision
last announcement
um
the scrutiny rights of the coffee
committee and the oversight rights of
the executive the European commission as
well the transparency and accountability
and as part of its evaluation of the EU
vaccine procurement strategy the
committee organized meeting as you know
with high-level Representatives on DJ
Sante DJ Hera pharmaceutical companies
European Ombudsman and European Court of
Auditors and following the coordinator's
decision I've also addressed a letter to
President metzola requiring to invite
President Van Der Lai for an in-camera
meeting to Parliament with a view to
providing answers on transparency and
accountability on joint procurement of
vaccines
and then as the last announcement the
committee coordinators adopted to the
draft program and list of participants
to the attack delegation to Cape Town
South Africa and Addis abiba Ethiopia
from the 26th to the 26th 20th to the
26th of February that is coming up soon
now
are there any
comments on the announcements
sorry I have to put on my
foreign
so then we can start
um on our public hearing before we enter
is
Mrs Anderson please
yeah
I do apologize I've got a bit mixed up
with my agenda I just wanted to make one
point
and I would like to expressly request
that as a committee we can take a
decision perhaps we can have a majority
resolution that we need a formal
investigative committee
particularly in light of the recent
events linked to Pfizer and the Pfizer
employees who've obviously been
divulging information
so I think it would be good if we could
investigate but the absolute minimum is
that the parliament
does organ
urgently need an investigative committee
and we as a committee can recommend that
to Parliament
so I think it would be essential for us
to come up with a resolution in order to
achieve that we as is your political
group to take an initiative either for a
resolution
or a resolution in combination with the
request for an inquiry committee that
you're of course are free to do so we
have a special committee that we just
extended for three months and based on
the decision of the coordinators we
proceed with everything I said in the
announcements and we will also now
proceed on the hearing and before well I
asked our two Specialists um to give an
introduction I'm very honored to have um
Mr Rafael glucksman
um remotely with us
um uh he's our colleague he's the chair
of the special committee on foreign
interference in all Democratic processes
in the European Union including this
information and I'm very I'm very happy
that you are here um Raphael and I'm I'm
happy to give you the floor to give a
seven minute five to seven minutes
introduction to this very important
hearing because I think your committee
is the expert and I think it's very good
are we close cooperate when it comes to
this information misinformations and
democracy and the pandemic not just
today but I think also important that we
can work closely together when we start
working on the report Mr glucksman I'll
give you the floor first
foreign
thank you dear Kathleen I'm very happy
that we organize the together this
session and that you invited us to your
very important committee and I'm sorry
I'm not able to attend physically the
the meeting but I'm very looking forward
to this exchange of view because for
more than two years now in our special
committee on fire interference what we
have
seen is that
at every crisis you have foreign power
interfering in our political debate and
the aim of these Powers especially
Russia and China is to actually
destabilize our democracies and polarize
our public debate and of course the
pandemia was a key moment in this
destabilization effort our democracies
were shaken we were facing an event that
was unprecedented not knowing really how
to tackle it and so it was a perfect
ground for a destabilization campaigns
and as I as I am always saying since the
beginning of our committee
well if somebody believes that the Earth
is flat it's not our problem as
legislator if somebody believes that the
vaccine is dangerous and that uh
actually it gives you a 5G in your arm
then it's not our problem as a
legislator but if
foreign entities or any entities launch
campaign in our cities so that hundreds
of thousands or millions of our fellow
citizens believe that the Earth is flat
or that the vaccine gives you the 5G in
your arm then it becomes our problem as
legislator we should not try to forbid
opinions but what we should do for sure
is to make sure that people can form
their own opinion without being subject
to foreign interference and foreign
regime autocratic ones not allowing any
form of distance in their own countries
in order to actually make out democracy
dysfunctional and that's what we have
witnessed during the pandemia what we
have witnessed is an effort to thread
lies in how to be debate on
the pandemia itself where it came from
and
also on the way to treat it and to
promote vaccination on a vaccination
and this is
clearly a typical case of
destabilization campaign we are not
dealing just with fake news or false
information we are dealing with
strategies coming from political
entities foreign regimes that really aim
at destabilizing our democracies and
undermine the trust in our institutions
and if we take a look back what what
happened you had on the one side this
disinformation campaign and on the other
side you had cyber attacks on the
European agents and medication you had
cyber attacks against hospitals so
clearly the objective
was to uh on the top of the crisis that
our European Democracies were facing
was to make us dysfunctional
and this is something that you have to
understand if you are focused
on an event or on a specific angle of
the public debate you might not have the
general picture and what we have tried
to do for the last two years in our
special committee is to understand the
general picture and the general picture
is that we are part of a hybrid Warfare
and that we are under attack
and every single event and so the
pandemia being a total event a
fundamental event more than any other
ones uh every single event is used in
order to uh actually make us believe
that democracy is not working and that
our institutions are to be blamed for
whatever happens in our societies
and this is something that goes well
beyond
right left Center
or greens or any political groups
because one thing that we need to share
is to make sure that the framework of
our disagreement
the general framework of our debate is
safe from foreign interference
and this was not the case during the
pandemia and this was not the case until
now and this is still not the case so
what we should do is to be very
realistic in the assessment of our
weakness
of our problems in order to shape a
better framework for our public debate
it's democracy the fact that we don't
believe the same thing
and that we actually have a relation to
opinion that is perfectly understanding
that opinions are
relative
and that's our public life is based on
the fact that people would disagree on
Solutions or on problems
but they have to disagree in on the
field that is not a tool in the hands of
foreign regime and what we have seen
during the pandema is also the problem
that we have in relation to the Social
Network companies and owners
of course social networks are huge
progress in public that's for public
participation but at the same time it
cannot be a Far West without Rule and
for that the European Union is at the
Forefront of the atom to regulate and
but the frame to the to the debate of a
public social networks and so I'm very
happy that uh you decided to touch this
subject and and to discuss it because I
think that
the pandemia being one of the two main
events that we have been confronted with
you at the pandemia and the war during
our mandate
it's really important uh to understand
all of the Logics that shaped the debate
around this uh event and one of them
being the attempt of malicious actor to
seed
mistrust and
antagonism in our public life
and this we cannot allow and this we
have to fight so thank you so much and
I'm looking forward to the exchange
thank you very much Mr glucksman for
this excellent introduction I think um
that makes my task really very easy I
don't have to give any further
introduction and we can move immediately
to our two Experts of our first half of
the hearing of today
next to me and present in the room is Mr
Edward Lucas a journalist and Senior
fellow at the center for European policy
analysis sepa and online Professor
Dimitra dimatra copulo who's a research
scientist at the center for constructive
communication Massachusetts oh sorry
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
um and I give first the floor to uh to
the professor
um for seven to ten minutes and then I
Turn to You Mr Lucas for the same uh
time and then we go to the questions
you have the floor
I'm chair and dear members of the
special committee on the covenanting
pandemic thank you so much for the honor
to participate in this public hearing
and the opportunity to address the
committee on such an important issue
uh my goal with my presentation today is
to map out the complexities associated
with vaccine hesitancy and contribute to
our Collective understanding of why
communication efforts often fail and
what could be a possible way forward
next slide please
globally information on covid-19 has
often been fluid and conflicting and
this along with the politicization of
governmental responses to the pandemic
has erode the trust in public health
institutions leaving ample room for the
rapid spread of misinformation next
slide
while surveys surveys can provide
representative metrics for document
documenting vaccine hesitancy messaging
efforts require more nuanced insights
into this skepticism there is a need to
study people's perceptions and mental
models around vaccination and explore
how prior lived experiences have
affected their reasoning behavior and
decision making
next
communicating scientific results
especially scientific uncertainty is a
challenging task as they carry complex
processes shifts and constraints that
are difficult to communicate next
so this difficulty in convincing the
public has revealed an ailing
relationship between science and its end
users at the same time official public
health communication that is ambiguous
jargon heavy or even complicated often
falls short of resonating with the
public
next
prior research has indicated that public
participation appears as an ideal
solution for the growing gap between
science and Society
so in line with research that indicates
the need for an upstream public
engagement we argue the need for
introducing to public health
communication deep listening approaches
to establish systematic dialogues with
communities and surface their
perceptions and misconceptions related
to vaccination
next slide
so the argument that I want to make
today is that listening to and
unraveling how people talk about their
concerns and fears as well as how they
associate them with prior lived
experiences is a powerful framework that
allows us to gain insight into what is
Meaningful for them
so in our research we have shown that
this approach can contribute to
understanding what messaging approach
would resonate with the public and
rather than trying to persuade help
address concerns with actionable
information
next slide
so to support these listening efforts in
a variety of contexts we have developed
technology at the MIT Center for
constructive communication that allows
us to explore people's lived experiences
as a way of creating shared
understanding learning and connection
the transcripts of these dialogues can
be explored as text and voice and
through state-of-the-art topic modeling
as you can see in the short clip
help us identify key topics that
surfaced during the conversations
next slide
so we use this technology to host over
50 dialogue groups since 2020 to capture
people's lived experiences as a means of
understanding hopes and concerns around
the covid-19 vaccine
today I will focus on my most recent
study drawing on data from 15 dialogue
groups with 60 parents of young children
across the United States to provide
insights into their fears and concerns
about the Pediatric covenanting vaccine
you see two different examples of
studies here I will focus on the second
next slide please
so after the conversations were
transcribed we identified a set of
prominent topics that you can see here
I'd like to play now and a short audio
clip to bring in the voices of
participants to my study expressing
their experiences and sentiments can we
move to the next slide and play the clip
please thank you
so new and something that's being so
forced down our throat big thing would
be to have the majority of the sources
relaying the same message who am I
listening to what am I going to believe
at the beginning they were like oh we
need to get a vaccine that will protect
us but once they realize that if you get
the vaccine you can still get covered
they should have been honest nobody
seems to be on the same page everybody
says trust my science but whose science
am I supposed to trust for my family and
I from March of 2020 we did not leave
the house once the vaccine was available
my wife and I both got it we were happy
there was a weight lifted off of our
shoulders and then I contracted covid
and I was very angry very upset I had
gone through this vaccination that was
promised to me to really just prevent
covet they need to be consistent they
need to figure out what their message is
and then use it but they're just kind of
going in circles and being honest trust
makes me want to dig my heels in more
and say now that you're forcing me I
don't want to do it and I hate to be
that immature but that's what it feels
like you're telling me to put this stuff
in my arm and then I'm just supposed to
wish it to work I know science has
explained it in certain aspects but I'm
not a scientist I'm just a stay-at-home
mom yes
is scary as a parent that is scary
knowing that not even making a decision
could have a consequence it's intuition
I know what I want to do
I don't have to be told I Rely mostly on
my intuition from the beginning it was
just pushed too far and it's pushed too
hard I've had enough I'm not I'm not
listening to this anymore
thank you and we can move to the next
slide
so after we wrapped up this study uh our
next goal was to use this insights to
directly inform the design of a
large-scale experiment to compare the
resonance and the effectiveness of the
bespoke messages we designed to and
compare those to mainstream Public
Health messaging mostly drawing on
language from the CDC and The Who
so the hypotheses that we were able to
confirm was that parents appear
significantly more open to listening to
a trusted Medical Professional and
discuss their fears and concerns we can
move to the next slide when they are
approached with empathy when their
feelings are validated and they perceive
the message as empathetic with tone and
language that aims to decompress rather
than scare them and forcing them into a
solution so that they could feel that
they are part also of the solution and
not part of the problem
next slide
so rather than the top-down approach
followed by many stakeholders who
usually tell the public what to do and
what they should think or worry about
our findings suggests that public health
messaging efforts can benefit from
employing Deep listening approaches as a
way to unravel public thought and
sentiment
next slide
such processes can offer deep insights
into the communities they aspire to
serve help them understand what kind of
actionable and relatable information
would efficiently address people's fears
and concerns and ultimately help address
and remedy many of the misconceptions
and ill-informed assumptions and Bridge
social divides next
apart from designing constructive
communication tools to bridge people
across experiences and divides our
Research Center has been focusing on
identifying who are the social media
actors with the greatest influence in
the context of the pandemic next slide
for This research we examine Twitter
Facebook and Instagram pandemic related
posts from January 2020 to January 2022
in order to rank influencers by the
total impact their covid-19 posts have
on pandemic narratives using total post
engagements next slide
we then partnered with the Massachusetts
Department of Public Health to
categorize all social media accounts
into various types of influencers such
as traditional news politicians Public
Health Organization and others next
slide so as you can see in this graph
politicians and political influencers
are ranked among the most influential
ones where is more expected actors such
as medical experts and public health
organizations ranked among the least
influential ones next
for examples you can see here CDC and
who ranked 100th and 126 respectively
highlighting a real challenge for
official public health communication
actors to cut through the social media
noise and reach the public
next
to wrap up non-extractive dialogic
interactions can offer nuanced insights
into the stories and perspectives that
are the most important meaningful and
relatable to the public next
so what we argue is that this knowledge
of the context-specific factors that
affect decision making regarding the
kovi 19 vaccine is necessary for
generating actionable insights in turn
these insights can inform the deployment
of feedback loops between communities
and related stakeholders by addressing
and ingesting specific questions and
concerns and this feedback can be then
translated into actionable and relatable
information that can be targeted back to
the communities thus enhancing the
efficiency of Public Health policies and
guidelines and inspiring more trusted
relationships with the public thank you
for your attention
foreign
professor and I'm sure there will be a
lot of questions but I first want to
give the floor to Mr Lucas for your
introduction you have the floor
thank you very much Madam chairman and
honorable members of the committee it's
a great honor to have the opportunity to
address this subject
I've spent the past 40 years as a
journalist as an author commentator and
consultant
working for news outlets including the
BBC and The Economist but also
specializing in Soviet and then Russian
information Warfare efforts part of the
wider portfolio of active measures used
to attack our democracies
I've also edited a weekly bulletin on
Chinese influence operations I've
written five books and quite a few
reports including one a few years ago
with an Applebaum and Peter pomeran Sev
which was the first full-length Think
Tank study of Russian information
operations this was at a time when
people thought it was rather unlikely
that either Russia or China would be
able to conduct information operations
in a well-established democracy
and I've written two lengthy reports on
Chinese operations
um in the kovid context I won't go into
the conclusions here but they're in my
written evidence one's called
information Bedlam and the other one is
jabbed in the back
really big point I want to make here is
that the means and the ends are
different
kovid was a huge opportunity for hostile
States
the fact that it's involved this
particular virus with this particular
origin possibly in Wuhan possibly not
that it's spread in this particular way
that it was countered with vaccines and
other therapeutic interventions that it
involved lockdowns with all the costs
and benefits Associated that is not the
fundamental point point was that it
created a period of enormous political
economic social
cultural psychological stress on Western
societies and that stress provided an
opportunity for hostile states to attack
us
and they did it in two broad ways and my
friend Rafael gluxman has outlined this
already I won't go into it in any great
detail but the first big thing was to
sow public mistrust
you think you're living in a democracy
you're not you're being bossed around
you think your leaders have their
interest your interests at heart
they don't they are working for shadowy
forces
um they're using this pandemic to do bad
things to you so that great battering
ram of public mistrust
um was one thing and the other and this
is particularly China rather than Russia
was to try and get the idea across that
an authoritarian country responds much
better to crises than a democracy does
that China was able to do things because
of its system that the West couldn't do
it's cut the death toll locked down more
effectively it developed vaccines faster
it was able to get vaccines to the rest
of the world more effectively and of
course in some senses that was true we
saw that there were many Western
failures during the covid epidemic
particularly in providing vaccines to
poor countries and that was something
where
um existing mistrust of the rich world
could be played on very successfully by
the Chinese
um who are supplying their vaccines at a
time when we weren't doing any but I'm
not here to talk about the politics of
our response who did what when how he
decided what we did and whether we did
it in the right way or not
I want to talk about the vulnerabilities
of our information system and how we can
fix it
now I should say although I've spent my
life as a journalist and I'm a fervent
defender of the Free Press I do differ
from some of my colleagues about the
role of the Free Press and the Democracy
in that I think that you can't leave it
just up to commercial competition I
Believe In Media Freedom that media
freedom is a necessary and not a
sufficient condition for the health of a
democracy
um it's not enough just to have
competition competition is great in that
it raises standards at the top
segment of the media Market you have the
economist competing with the uh
ft the Frankfurter algarminer competing
with the sudo Deutsche title and so on
and that's great and at the bottom
competition lower standards but in the
end in a competitive environment outside
actors will get involved and they will
do things that are bad for our democracy
and we have to be aware of that
I wrote a report on this
um for the um National Endowment for
democracy in Washington DC and
um outlined my points in detail there so
I'll just summarize them but the first
point is that one about competition
simply leave it to the market you allow
the wealthy to buy influence and that
can be a wealthy business or it can be a
wealthy country a country that is
willing to devote money
um to influencing other democracies and
they will subsidize media Outlets that
protect and promote their point of view
and try and punish the ones that don't
so if you allow commercial pressure
alone to dictate information flows
you're effectively selling political
decision making to the highest bidder
I wouldn't pay particular attention to
financial intimidation I speak as
someone who comes from Britain which is
the ground zero for slaps strategic
lawsuits against public participation
this is where wealthy individuals or
businesses or people working with
hostile States in some cases use the
extremely expensive legal system to
intimidate uh and silence their critics
Sometimes using defamation law Sometimes
using Privacy Law Sometimes using data
Protection Law or indeed a mixture of
all three and that kills the truth and
where you kill the truth it's easier for
falsehood to flourish
it should come as no surprise to people
on the committee that Russia disrupts
and subverts the information system of
the countries it targets
um it's also worth noticing that China
has a sharp power strategy that also
involves
um weaponizing information
collaborating and subverting mainstream
media Outlets but also trying to gain
influence over the dissemination
infrastructure to things like Tick Tock
or WeChat information platforms where
it's impossible
um to say something that the Chinese
Communist party doesn't like talk to
your Australian colleagues about what
it's like trying to win the attention
and support of Chinese Ethnic Chinese
voters in Australia when you can't say
on WeChat things that the Chinese
Communist party doesn't like and WeChat
is effectively the only means of
reaching those voices
there's another problem which is the
fair-mindedness and newsworthiness of
the journalistic mentality we want to be
fair and we want the news to be exciting
that's normal
and the problem with that is that fair
mindedness leads to Lazy moral
equivalents this scientist says that the
vaccine is safe
and this guy over here on Twitter or
Facebook or somewhere says he's a
scientist and he says the vaccine's not
safe so
two points of view I'll leave it to the
readers to make their mind up but that's
lazy when I'm training journalists which
I have done over many years I always say
if you have two sources one says it's
raining outside and the other says it's
not raining outside your job as a
journalist is not to report that
somebody somebody says it's raining and
somebody says it's not raining your job
is to go outside and see if it is
raining or not and then write the story
accordingly
so fair-mindedness can be a trap and
also newsworthiness
um the desire to be first the devotions
are to be funny the desire to be
eye-catching can sometimes take
precedence over uh the important
fundamental news values of the story and
you see this particularly in moments of
great Panic like over covid and if
someone says oh my goodness here is a
scientific discovery that turns
everything you thought on your head and
this chemical which we normally feed to
horses or put down drains or something
can cure covid well then you think I
want to be first with that story and you
stick it online or print it or put it on
the airwaves and you may be doing
everyone a disservice
now there's no easy answer to this
there's not a clear binary dividing line
between misinformation or disinformation
and good information just as there's not
a clear dividing line between old media
and New Media and there's not a clear
dividing line between responsible
journalism and Fringe journalism and so
I urge the members of the committee do
not go into this thinking that there is
an easy answer if there was an easy
answer we'd have found it these
decisions and our reactions about how to
deal with this threat go into very deep
Waters about the way in which we trust
each other the way in which we
communicate to each other the sort of
freedoms that we allow each other so I
have a series of suggestions which I'll
get on to but none of them is a
so-called Silver Bullet
the first thing I think we need to do is
to name the problem
I was struck in the questions that I was
sent about reference to certain non-eu
States
we have to be absolutely clear that we
are under attack wherever you live in
the Democratic world you are in a world
of geopolitical competition where
hostile State actors particularly Russia
and China but one could also say North
Korea and Iran have very different ideas
about about how the world is going to be
run and they will do things to get their
agenda on to our agenda and to make
things happen and I still worry that
many of us are living in a kind of post
1991 la la land where we think that
everything thing can be solved by
dialogue and it's just a final world out
there we just have to talk a bit more
and confront a bit less well I'm sorry
that's not the case and we saw very
clearly during the pandemic in this
moment of great human emergency that
there were countries that were willing
to weaponize that moment and attack us
casting doubt on the efficacy of our
vaccines people die because of that and
that was something that both Russian and
Chinese statement media were willing to
do for political reasons
so we Face serious threats and the most
important thing I want to say about
information threats is just because
they're the ones you notice doesn't mean
that they're the ones that matter we
tend to think that the bit of the
problem we can see is the most important
bit of the problem no information
operations are by their nature often
visible because they leak out into the
public but they are just part of the
whole toolkit of responses and tactics
that the Chinese Communist party and the
Kremlin and our other geopolitical
adversaries are willing to deploy they
can also use economic means turning are
attacking our supply chain whether it's
for energy or for something else they
can use cyber attacks they can use
psychological warfare they can use
diplomatic dividing rule tactics they
have an entire range of tactics they
will use and information is often used
in conjunction with those it's very rare
in my experience there's an information
operation purely consists of information
and anything else so look at the whole
Iceberg not just the bid that you can
see
foreign once you've named the problem
the next thing to do is to monitor it
get an idea of what's really going on
ask hard questions about not just
content but about motives it's a really
good test if you're looking at something
that tends to be a news Outlet to ask
what's the editorial code of conduct
if there isn't one ask why what's the
policy on apologies and Corrections
because any legitimate news organization
will make mistakes we never have enough
room we never have enough time there
will always be mistakes
the question is how you deal with them
a responsible reputable news Outlet will
have a policy on Corrections and it will
print them in a prominent position
um saying yes we got this wrong it
wasn't X it was y
for years when I was talking about
Russia today as it was called then I
would use this as an example and ask
people if they could find any occasion
on which RT had ever published and a
correctional or apology the answer was
there was one buried very deep in its
website well that's changed a bit now
and that's good but it's still an
excellent question to ask look at the
motives are news organizations run by a
state are they operating according to
political agenda are they solely focused
on profitability some of our biggest
problems with disinformation are people
who are solely interested in generating
kicks and they know that disinformation
generates more kicks it's more
interesting than boring old true
information and that's what they do
so Monitor and analyze the problem
then we need to build defenses and take
countermeasures and this is perhaps the
most controversial bit
well let's start with defenses media
education I'm sure there is members of
the European Parliament here from
Finland
looking around hopefully to see if there
any fins here that's good could Finn's
hate being praised in public it makes
them very unhappy and embarrassed so
with no fins in the room possibly not
even Finnish translators I see the booth
is empty well I can go ahead and praise
Finland because Finland teaches media
literacy from the get-go pretty much as
soon as you learn to read and there are
other countries that are very good at
this but you need to bake in media
literacy into your education system but
don't and you start with children but
don't stop there it's about everything
that you do in the public messaging
space is to build up people's mental and
cultural muscles so they can see when
they're being lied to when they're being
persuaded when they're being misled and
they can react accordingly we need to
think about Norm building we need people
to feel whether they're in public health
or the media or in Academia on
government on the police on the
intelligence service or wherever you're
not operating in a silo and public
health exemplifies this public health
only works if public health
professionals will talk to the media and
if the media will think about how they
write about public health and we've seen
plenty of examples in the past few years
to show the statistical illiteracy of
the media
people tend to go into journalism
because they're good at words not
because they're good at numbers and that
really matters when you're talking about
epidemiology so we need to work on Norm
building and education all across Civil
Society the media
seeing it through a public health and
National Security context we already do
this actually with mental illness and
with suicide in many countries any
report of a suicide will have a little
thing at the end saying if you're
feeling suicidal or if you need help
call this number so we kind of know how
to do this we just need to do it more we
need to reward good journalism and we
need to punish vaginalism I would not
include the criminal justice system in
this but we can do things on that front
we can have regulatory Frameworks and
better identity Assurance to make it
harder for Bad actors to operate
anonymously I look forward to your
questions thank you very much indeed for
hosting me thank you very much Mr Lucas
I gave you a little bit more time I'm
very grateful but it was very
interesting and I did want you to to end
also with um well with some proposals to
deal with it and it's also important for
our report but I um also for um ingay
who will go much more in depth but also
France are very important so thank you
very much for that and I now go
immediately to the political groups and
I start of course with Mr kimbropoulos
please can you indicate to whom you
raised the question yes of course
[Music]
well two useful presentations in this
room but for that I would like to thank
the the artist for being with us
one of the main Lessons Learned From
This pandemic was they need to
effectively communicate complex research
problems in an easy to understand manner
but also they need to understand the
specificities of population across the
member style member states and finally
the ability to tailor our messages to
meet different demographics information
needs and attitudes
as a Mr Luca said
there was no Silver Bullet in doing that
in my opinion we're working boys or
another metabolic may not work for a
rural area or in Ireland
having this in mind in many countries
public institutions do they burst to
provide answers and address a certainty
and announce about the burdening
problems
and of course one of the mentalities was
held to explain that scientific advice
and measures contained from One Day by
another in light of the emerging
evidence and epidemiological data
but also how to explain the differences
in pandemic response across neighboring
neighbor States
there was not easy to communicate a club
enabled for people's trust prostitutions
and they'll be favored in this regard I
want to ask Professor Dimitar kobulio
I'm not going to study participants what
was the main factors leading to the
increase interest in media and social
institutions secondly how did the cope
with the uncertainty about the pandemic
and finally what which kind of
information and Dada did the value most
and which affected them in making their
decisions thank you very much thank you
very much Mrs please
thank you Kathleen I have a question for
both speakers thank you very much for
your presentations uh for Professor
Dimitra we are starting to see
vaccination hesitancy even for vaccines
like folio polio mealitis is a deadly
disease that was eliminated in most
parts of the world however it's now
raising its incidents in some parts of
the world and we are now leaving vaccine
hesitancy before the pandemic but it was
intensified beyond the pandemic and
according to your findings what are the
main hesitancy factors related to
vaccination for current and future
diseases that may arise I give the
example for instance of the new vaccines
for Ebola for malaria
tuberculosis are are having new findings
and by your research will this be
constricted to covid only or to all
vaccine preventable diseases and second
question for you that you showed in your
research that people have more trust in
politicians than in public health
authorities if I saw it correctly and is
this due to the heart and Technical
scientific language of this public
health authorities various politicians
are used to speaking to the public with
more engaging and simpler messages or do
you have any other perspective on this
and my question to Mr Lucas is that you
you spoke about the one of what we can
do to overcome it and one is to check
the editorial code of conduct but is
this a suggestion for whom for us
politicians for The Wider public how can
this be translated translated to the
masses because we're now talking and
here in the year we're talking about 450
million citizens and second part of my
question is you spoke about public
health and media and public health is by
its wide definition and the science of
promoting Health preventing disease
prolonging life to the organized efforts
of society so by its definition it does
not work in silos however I'm a medical
doctor in the public health field and
what I saw in the pandemic and whenever
every media came to me with the
microphone they were waiting for me to
give them any Jewish parts and they were
not uh let's say interested in the
message the public health message I was
trying to convey as a professional so my
question here is how can we overcome
this part where the media itself it's uh
it's looking for the more juicy parts
and not the message that doesn't get
more clicks thank you very much salsara
I first go for the answers to Professor
Dimitri Dimitra coppolo
for the answers and then I come to Mr
Lucas Professor yes please
thank you uh so first I would like to
address uh the question of Mr
kimberopoulos uh first of all I couldn't
agree with you more uh political social
and cultural context can definitely be
different and they need to be taken into
account When developing messages and
public health communication campaigns
one message that can work for one
context may not work for another however
what the pandemic uh showed us was that
it was an event that was experienced
globally so many of the concerns many of
the fears that people addressed in the
context of the epidemic were indeed
um Global and
um common uh up to a certain extent so
um
one important factor in people's vaccine
hesitancy is the lack of trust so the
pandemic happened at the time when the
lack of trust in institutions political
institutions Public Health institutions
social institutions was very low
um and it became very obvious that in
such a context when the lack of trust
was widespread and experienced globally
um people wouldn't just trust
automatically the messages and the
information that was that was relayed to
them
so that created a lot of uncertainty
people felt very confused it was a very
complicated event it was a very
complicated Public Health Emergency uh
and people were just hungry for
information and data uh and
having said that science wasn't moving
with the same speed as this hunger and
desire of people to get updated
information so scientists and experts
and public health experts were
communicating data and information
um as they were able you know to figure
things out
um but of course scientific
um evidence shifted because this is how
science works but that created even more
confusion to the people who started
seeing these shifts as inconsistency not
as a as a not it wasn't enough for
reason for them to understand that this
is how science works so that created
another challenge people were are aware
and are scientific um illiterate so that
means that we haven't done a good job in
communicating how science works and why
some scientific findings may come up and
my be timely
right then but after a while since
science advances these results may not
be relevant anymore or maybe replaced by
other newer uh and more advanced science
so
um to your last point about what
information and data would be valued
more people were anxious to
um
have exposure to data and information
that could help them address their
concerns what I have heard from hundreds
of people in my research is that expert
public health communication is often
perceived as imposed something that is
forced you were able to also hear that
in
um some in the audio clip that I shared
with you that was it was a very it was a
very common pattern people were confused
people wanted to
um the different institutions and
authorities to be more honest in terms
of what works and what are the things
that they're not certain about
uh to Mr to Mrs uh cerdas
um you asked about what could be the
reasons for vaccine hesitancy
um I could highlight
um three major ones first was the lack
of trust in institutions as I also I
shared in my previous response
um that played uh a very large role so
uh people didn't trust and still don't
trust the government or public health
authorities the scientific community so
this lack of trust had a very direct
impact into people feeling hesitant and
skeptical about the vaccine the second
one was the politicization of the virus
and the vaccine
um we saw that a lot of politicians made
this
um made the pandemic an ideological
um debate it wasn't about trusting the
science it was about who which
politician and which political party was
really relaying a message that was
relevant to the people
and then the third reason is mixed
messaging different sources different
stakeholders were communicating
different messages so
um people just felt completely lost they
didn't know who who to trust who was
relaying
um the message that was that was right
and just you know a clarifying Point
um our results don't indicate that
people trusted politicians more they
indicate that actually politicians have
been more influential in terms of how
popular and engaging their social media
posts are
and I think this is this reflects how
the pandemic became a political and
ideological issue so people
weren't looking for the right
information or the scientifically backed
information but the ones but the
information that was consistent with
their political and ideological beliefs
thank you very much Mr Lucas please
um it's a privilege to have questions
from a psychiatrist and from a medical
doctor
um I um I think the point about the
editoral codes of conduct is that
you get them through Norm building I
don't think you can make a law that you
have it but for example if you are
accrediting a news organization to an
event you can say
um please link to your code of conduct
and once it becomes in some countries
it's considered very normal to do this
and others it's not but you can build
the norm over time
um it's not a Magic Bullet but once
people have committed to do to doing
something then when they don't do it you
can you have a better chance of of
um shaming them in public
but I think your your second Point goes
to the heart of the issue it is is
really difficult
we have a competitive news media that
wants an exciting story and you have
science with all the difficulties of and
reservations and qualifications
as a part of the scientific process
and I think the answer is you have to
start before you get to that point by
practicing so we need to be rehearsing
and we should have rehearsed before this
pandemic
um how do we do Public Health messaging
and pandemics and you start off at quite
a high level with meetings of editors
and Senior figures in government and
Academia and Science and so on and do
simulations and scenarios and start
working out do we need to train
journalists differently what are the
rules going to to be what our Norms
going to be
um I hope we've learned some lessons
from this pandemic we certainly haven't
learned all of them I think it's also
important to give scientists good
training and medical doctors and how to
handle media not all media is the same
the person shoving a microphone in your
face may not be the person you actually
need to speak to
and we saw in in my country in Britain
some quite sophisticated news management
by the people who are developing the
Oxford vaccine who gave very few
interviews until they had something that
they were absolutely confident that they
wanted to say publicly but again you
don't necessarily grow up with these
skills if you spent your time in
laboratory and we have so we need to do
a much better job in training everybody
involved because this is going to happen
again
foreign
[Music]
thank you very much Madam I'm going to
talk speaking French
first of all let me thank both the
speakers for the quality of those
comments I think your contributions will
be very useful to us when we produce our
report
now disinformation
is a very significant when it relates to
health because it's a threat to human
life and that is why the who has said
that health disinformation during the
crisis was a full stemic
and so it's a particular problem
it's not just trivial it costs a lot of
money I did read in the a report by the
University of Baltimore that up to 9
million a year is spent on health
disinformation now you've talked about
prevention
it seems to me that we can take two tax
here first of all we can focus on health
education for young people we can make
sure that they learn how to take
everything critically and be Discerning
but then there's also
um
information training for healthcare
professionals so there are many
health professionals in this committee
so including me you won't be surprised
to hear that but we were actually
shifted out of the spotlight both by
journalists and patients Healthcare
professionals
were asked seriously whether they should
people should be swallowing bleach every
morning
people were asking us if you received a
blood transfusion from someone who had
had the vaccine then you as an
unvaccinated person could be considered
to have impure blood and this is
information that was circulated by the
media and it came back to the healthcare
Professionals in the form of questions
from patients
so there needs to be a way of protecting
Healthcare professionals by teaching
them how best to respond to this kind of
question because we don't have the
training for this we're not accustomed
to hearing this kind of
question
we're not supposed to deal with
disinformation
so it'd be very useful if you could give
us some ideas for how to deal with that
thank you very much
thank you chair and thank you to The
Experts for being with us another
Healthcare professionals sitting here
I'm a pharmacist by training and I I
would like to compliment we were not
trained how to talk to patients we were
not trained how to bring cross messages
that were actually important for
Patients health at least we were not
trained at University I mean of course I
did do some training but that was well I
was already on the job because I wanted
to do it I wanted to learn how to
communicate best with my patients in
order to make sure that they do the
compliance to the medicines which were
prescribed to them or also to whatever
else would be important for their health
so I think that's one of the issues that
usually the healthcare professionals are
not experts in communication they are
not experts in how to talk to people how
to create messages that are consistent
and that stick but I think and I would
like to hear the opinion of both the
experts on this is one of the problems
was also that um
we had
different
Healthcare professionals with different
views on the pandemic I mean I'm talking
on the situation in Germany where we had
klauschter who was previously had been
working for The Who and he was like well
this is just a flu don't worry and that
of course did not help a lot and
um actually I I did read very very much
during those especially during those
months where we were more or less
Homebound and could not could not go to
pariaman so I did browse around the
internet for studies and all that so I
built my own perception or I created my
own view on this
um but of course judging from what I
read and from sources that I thought
were trustworthy but I think
um the most important thing is really
the the politicization because if you're
already aligned to this is a Channel I
will not trust for example it's the BBC
and BBC are always taking government's
lines so I don't trust BBC in the first
place and we are actually experiencing
similar things right now when it comes
to Ukraine and Russia's aggression on
Ukraine where we have basically those
same channels that have been spreading
um distrust on vaccines and also on
non-pharmaceutical interventions now I
was saying well it's NATO's fault
because Russia had to
um had to invade Ukraine in order to
prevent NATO from Moscow or something so
how do you see this link there I would
be very interested Mr Lucas thanks thank
you very much Utah Mrs euron
oh I'm sorry this is your own but
um
yes thank you very much my first
question is for the professor Dimitri a
couple
so how could we
improve better access to information
awareness campaigns and especially in
terms of social media now the
information from your study
doesn't seem to be
present in your social
media profile I'm aware that your
YouTube channel doesn't have a huge
number of followers but I'm just
wondering how your studies Finance this
study that you presented today
was that used with was that
paid for I beg your partner with EU
commission money to EU taxpayers money
so
any information about the EU commission
and the vaccine contracts is considered
as fake news so they these vaccines were
bought with EU taxpayers money although
it's supposedly fake news we know from
the print media that there has been
pressure on Twitter and Facebook to
remove all critical comments the
German government has had to admit
that they have met with Representatives
so there is an unbearable Council
culture which targets scientists I am a
Scientist myself any scientists who are
critical of the vaccines are
suppressed but discussion and discourse
is dependent on differences in opinions
it's not up to a journalist as you said
Mr Lucas what is
right or wrong you have to present a
neutral position
so neutral reporting on studies that
show that there have been multiple
examples
of people whose immune systems have been
compromised
so I'm just wondering how are you going
to determine what is scientific fake
news and what is not perhaps you can
tell me exactly what you get up to
yourself as a specialist in fake news
and social media thank you very much
professor
yes
um
the um
the question from the French colleague
an oncologist I think if I'm not
mistaken
um you're absolutely right we don't have
and also use this question from the uh
as a pharmacist
which is not part of Medical Training
dealing with a media frenzy why should
it be
um but actually we need to we need at
least some people in the public health
world with very high-end media skills
and deep understandings of how
the public react in a public health
emergency and I think you only get that
you get that by training and by doing
simulations and practicing and Reckoning
this is getting this is going to happen
again I feel really sorry
um both for the healthcare professionals
who are suddenly thrown in front of TV
cameras and microphones and trying to
explain complicated things to people who
didn't seem to understand the basic
numbers I also feel quite sorry for
journalists who are told to go out and
cover this when they were pretty hazy on
the difference between a virus and a
bacterium perhaps some distant memory of
having done a little bit of science at
school 30 or 40 years ago and then
suddenly you're trying to to cover it so
there's plenty there's plenty to do and
there's no Silver Bullet
um on your question Mrs Lima I am
I'm not saying that journalists
um shouldn't be neutral I'm saying that
neutrality isn't the only answer if you
tell me it's raining
and
Mrs Van Brunt tells me it's not raining
as a journalist it's not my job just to
say one MEP says it's raining and the
other MEP says it's not raining it's my
job to find out is the water coming from
the sky and if there is not water coming
from the sky then the giant then the
someone The Source Who says that it was
uh raining has got some questions to
answer and vice versa so we have to dig
we have to ask hard questions and we
ultimately we make editorial judgments
every word that is printed reflects an
editorial judgment why did I decide to
do this topic and not that topic why did
I decide to put this fact first and not
that fact first so there is no such
thing as total neutrality journalism is
always about Choice
um I think I I don't think there is a
cancer culture on um
uh the scientific debate I think you
probably but I think it's true that
there are some people who don't feel
their views are taken as seriously as
other people and that unfortunately
that's that that that's life
um the uh
I think the answer to the people who I
think you probably agree with this come
up with some peer-reviewed studies that
actually show that there's something
wrong with the vaccine and so far we
don't have that
um if you can produce some peer-reviewed
studies then people start taking it
seriously as you say science is
fundamentally about argument but I think
it's reasonable for a journalist to say
hang on an individual doctor saying I
don't like this vaccine is not the same
as someone who's speaking with the
authority of a major research program
and why am I an expert well I've been
doing this
um since the 1980s I was covering Soviet
propaganda and Soviet attempts to attack
our democracies back then and I see the
same tactics working now the difference
is we have the internet with the
immediacy ubiquity and anonymity that
the internet brings which makes it much
more difficult when the Soviet Union was
trying to spread the lie that aids was
the product of a CIA bioweapons program
they had to go through enormous efforts
to get that into the
um Western mainstream media and they
succeeded but these days they would do
it from a phone like this which would
cost them small amounts of money it
would be basically it's frictionless and
so we have to rethink the way we
understand the information we're seeing
because it's coming at us in different
different ways
thank you very much
um professor
to give answers to the other questions
please
thank you so much first I would like to
Echo Mr Lucas's comments I couldn't
agree more
um and based on the questions I received
[Music]
um
Healthcare professionals
have not been trained how to talk to
patients they're not experts in
Communications and why shouldn't they be
uh they weren't asked to do that when
they started doing this profession uh
but now we live in a very complicated
world that is full of data full of
opinions and full of facts alternative
or not
people get constantly bombarded by
social media posts we have a rapid we
have a we have a an unprecedented
explosion of information people have
access to different sources and
different experts so we're all operating
in a very conflicting environment so
uh in my opinion we should prioritize
having training for
um the public
for public health professionals also
politicians to understand how we can
operate in this very complicated World
um first of all we need to focus on
making the public more aware of how
science works on how
um
Public Health emergencies can be
addressed we also need to provide
training to health professionals to help
them understand how can they talk to
patients in a more in a more empathetic
and relatable way because what the
pandemic has showed us is that people
are not convinced by the mere
presentation of facts
or data
hard data doesn't work for people
um there's too much noise in the social
media and people have are being exposed
to different opinions and they don't
know who to trust so when it comes down
to that answer people they just tend to
trust whoever they agree with so that's
why we're talking in this pandemic about
people operating in Eco Chambers people
are operating in silos because people
would just relate and Trust
the people and the experts who they
agree mostly with who sound more
um
relevant to their concerns so I believe
that we should prioritize creating
programs that can help public health
professionals understand how
um
lay people actually think and feel and
we should also help the public
understand complex scientific processes
by
bridging all these divides all of these
stakeholders they operate in their own
spaces in siled spaces and we don't have
organic connections that can help them
understand all the different challenges
and the pressure that they're all
operating under so in my research what I
am trying to do is to bridge those gaps
by bringing researchers and the public
together so that we can Embrace dialogue
as a means of understanding each other
better and create those connections and
Bridge social divides thank you
thank you very much
um I now go to Mrs de la Pizza
well my first
question is Mr Lucas I would like to
thank both of the guests for being here
today now a crisis is a very difficult
situation and you have sudden changes
and therefore governments and other
decision makers come out with
declarations which aren't always
entirely accurate and sometimes they
appear to be contradictory as the crisis
develops in the case of the pandemic we
found ourselves in an in unknown
territory
and so the governments and other
decision makers had to come out with
contradictory or apparently
contradictory information
and we have to recognize that that
actually had a negative impact on the
institutions and has undermined
confidence in the institutions but
the natural criticism of these decisions
is often dismissed or criticized in its
own right
I mean this idea that I've said you have
to do this so off you go that's not very
logical now we're hearing about China
and Russia who are engaged in attacks
but this is also a pre-text for avoiding
reflection on how much confidence we can
have in the institution Professor
Dimitra Coppola has talked about this so
we do have to have the present presence
of the doctors and of the Laboratories
and other scientists they didn't come
and present their information here but
we have heard a lot from political
speakers that's the reality
so we have noted that absence so my
question is
is this fake news not the outcome of
inconsistencies and contradictory
statements made by political decision
makers
and the danger is that this term fake
news can be used to limit freedom of
expression now Mr Lucas what exactly can
we do in order to
this
um to recognize that there's a
distinction between those who have
followed the official line and those who
have come up with alternative
angles
we know that social media is part of the
problem because it's not creating a
healthy balance of opinion Miss morody
Alessandra
grazia
thank you thank you madam and I would
like to thank both of the speakers
for the very interesting presentations
that they've made today it's very useful
contributions that you've made to our
discussions I've got a couple of
questions
first of all we know that disinformation
hasn't had negative impacts only on the
institutions by undermining their
credibility but we know that
mystification and fake news has also
increased unjustified
skepticism about
vaccines and doctors which has actually
threatened human life and there has been
anti-scientific propaganda and the
danger isn't just those who have
generated this fake news there's
actually been an attack on individuals
health
I would argue so professor
I would like to know whether you feel
that there should be more attention paid
to the origins of information so who is
generating information who is promoting
information in social media and in the
media
especially when we're dealing with human
health
and for Mr Lucas I would like to know
whether you feel
that there has been foreign interference
during the pandemic I think you've
already made this point but I'm just
wondering sir
which states would you like to name in
particular and is there a correlation
between the novax groups and certain
non-eu countries which were involved in
foreign interference thank you
is thank you chair for uh for this and
uh thank you very much for a very
interesting and necessary presentations
um I mean I I have been extremely
worried of course uh when observing the
the effect the impact of misinformation
and uh this information and especially
when it comes to the most vulnerable in
our groups take for example
um young people but also people with
just less knowledge on the topic or who
have less access to
um to to the information and sources of
information that for example
um we have so we see different groups
being affected by it because they have a
different level of access
to the right and correct information and
this is something that we have been
seeing and learning from during this
pandemic and it's very necessary that
that in your rope we we make the right
legislation to put in place like for
example the Digital Services act to make
sure that this information is not being
spread through social networks but still
these big tech companies have a big
responsibility to to
um to take so I don't see yet how
especially the most vulnerable in our
societies are going to be protected by
that because they're also very active
and they participate also in these
social media platforms so what I find
very important about this uh learning
from this pandemic is also how are we
going to Target
the most vulnerable ones in our society
and do we learn enough from this and do
we also learn from it in a way that we
can protect the most vulnerable
um against this information and
misinformation so what do you think we
should learn from that and how can we
more
um
effectively and more constructively
protect the most vulnerable groups
um in that sense thank you thank you
very much I first go now to Professor
Dimitra Dimitra copulo by the end of the
session I'll be able to pronounce your
name just perfectly
thank you for trying
um I'll try to group my responses for
the efficiency of time
um
as
I think everyone agrees we are operating
in a world where information is coming
from many different sources and people
have access to information
um and this sources can be any sources
uh from journalists experts policy
makers politicians and the social media
platforms have accumulated so much power
and giving voice to anyone who wants to
be heard so
we really cannot control who's
generating information or who has access
to what information and whether that
information is right or wrong
so in my opinion I think that we need to
help the public develop filters to be
able to filter all these
stream of information that is coming
from many different sources who are
uncontrollable
um
controlling the source of information
might seem as a very obvious thing to do
but it's a very challenging task because
we cannot control that even if you know
we have seen examples of social media
accounts being shut down because they
were identified as
um account spreading misinformation but
they will fake news and misinformation
will always find its way through they
may block some accounts these actors who
want deliberately to spread
misinformation they will find another
way they will they will create different
um accounts they will move to different
platforms so we can really not control
the origin of information but what we
can help with is to allow people to
develop these filters so that they can
block misinformation and and facts that
are not scientifically backed uh or
verified and we need to do that through
education
the pandemic is already you know we're
three years past the pandemic
we have learned a lot we have all
suffered a lot and at the same time I
think this creates uh and very important
opportunity to reflect on what happened
what are the lessons you learned and how
can we find a way forward how can we
help people block misinformation not
just related to the pandemic we see
misinformation spreading across many
different
spaces and areas so that's what I would
you know personally like to prioritize
because as Mrs Rafael also mentioned we
need to prioritize how to protect the
most vulnerable we cannot expect that
people can become experts in public
health matters or any kind of matters so
in order to do that we need to help them
and in order to help them we need first
to understand what are their needs what
are their concerns so whatever we come
up with this this can be
targeted to an address and this can
address the the specific challenges that
they're facing in their everyday lives
so I think we need to prioritize
to listen to people to listen to members
of the public to understand what are
their concerns what do they really care
about and what are their perspectives
and approaches to different kinds of
data
stories information that can really help
them make an informed decision thank you
thank you very much Mr Lucas please
it's a very long list of of questions
and I'll try and deal with the most
important ones in greatest depth I think
my framing point would be that it's
quite normal that our normative and
regulative response comes behind
technological change at first we
invented the motor car
then we decided
how to
um have mass motive Transportation with
traffic lights and Road signals and and
so on and it's the same with the
internet the internet produces huge new
challenges and evolution has not
equipped us well for this and we're
still working on it so it's it's natural
we have a lot of difficulties
I think that anonymity is really
difficult and I we are not at all good
at dealing with Anonymous information
and particularly on Anonymous
information that comes in a kind of
synthetic way that it looks real and I
would really urge lawmakers including
this committee to push the tech
companies very hard on that we were
getting somewhere with identity
Assurance a few years ago with thick
authenticated Facebook accounts and blue
ticks and so on and that was beginning
to create a sort of ecosystem which you
could see this really is Mrs Van Brunt
tweeting not someone who just uses her
name and her picture and we've gone
backwards on that and that's bad so
please light a fire under the tech
companies on that I I'm not here to
defend the government's um pandemic
response in any country I'm in favor of
humility I don't think there's any
country that got it completely right if
this was the military we would be doing
an after action review and saying what
are the Lessons Learned
um everybody should look back on what
they did and work out whether they
should have done it better or
differently and I don't think there's a
single scientist a single Hospital a
single doctor or a single journalist you
can look back and say yes we got this
100 right but as I said before do let's
practice because more pandemics
coming
I I the German word minus bildong is
very useful here it doesn't really
translate easily but it's the job of the
media to create a sort of public
conscience and public Consciousness
about things and that gets back to my
ideas that journalists are not just
simply involved in a um in a political
um in in a commercial business business
most of the misinformation
disinformation and scare stories and
rumors were endogenous they're created
within our society
um as I said before there's no clear
dividing line between stuff that's true
and stuff that's false because most
stuff that's true has mistakes in it and
there's stuff that's false will have
grains of Truth
um but my point at the beginning was
that China weaponized the stress of the
pandemic to try and sow discontent as
did Russia and there are plenty of
examples of that
um in the reports that I've cited
um just look at the kind of RT coverage
of the pandemic or what global times
would say the Chinese State Outlet
um
I think I particularly like what you
said Raphael we need to think
particularly about low low information
um consumers in other parts of public
life we worry about the most vulnerable
um bottom fifth of the population the
worst house the ones with the worst
Health are the ones with the worst life
chances and so on well we should worry
about the ones who get the worst
information as well and pay particular
attention I'm not really worried about
people who can afford to read The
Economist and the ft and the New York
Times and then compare the three of them
I'm worried about people who don't have
money to buy good information and are
perhaps not equipped through the
education they've had and the life they
lead to make
um good sense of the information they do
receive
um I'll stop there
thank you very much and however the last
questions
um for our two experts um and I started
with Mrs divasi
um
thank you chair
I have to admit that this topic is
pretty incredible we're talking about
this information
uh and he actually wrote about this in
your report and I really liked this you
mentioned that we need to trust
institutions
and there's a demand for transparency
from the citizens
and
this is a very important element there
were many reports that show that
institutions weren't completely coherent
to give the example of France we were
told first that masks were useless then
we had to wear masks
and within people this also Fosters a
sense of distrust and when there's
distrust people start looking
for something they can't trust and
something other something else that's
very important is credibility
we had experts who were doctors or
researchers and they had links with
pharmaceutical labs
and this adds fuel to the fire of
distrust
I'll give you a few examples when we saw
the Twitter files because now the uh
Twitter has a new owner and Elon Musk
wanted to put everything out on the
table and he published files that show
that certain labs and certain
governments were pushing to eliminate
tweets
tweet switch were asking about
free access to covid
technology so that uh vaccines could be
a common uh you know could be more
easily accessed
or a development of vaccines in
developing economies these were removed
when there were critiques of
pharmaceutical Labs those were removed
when there were critiques about
Labs well I'm a biological researcher so
I know about research and I had my own
critiques
and this actually comes up in the
Twitter files that these types of
criticisms were removed
so doctors nurses
Common People asked questions and they
were placed in a box of conspiracy
theorists there was no debate
you're talking about this information
always going in one way talking about
Chinese people Russians
but there were people who were asking
questions and they weren't allowed to
ask those questions
and this was a huge problem this
actually
was a principal problem during the
covert crisis and I was hoping that you
would make uh some concrete proposals
we shouldn't just include experts but
normal people who can ask their
questions should also have a a platform
you are not talking about this
the mainstream media have a platform but
media who asked questions didn't weren't
allowed to speak
so you're only
um helping out fake news because then
people don't believe end up not
believing anything and when people don't
believe anything how can you run a
country
I think we need to speak about honesty
credibility
people who aren't paid
or who don't have a profit motive I
think you're not critical enough about
what happened
uh
because we could have learned something
from all this
please
thank you madam chair thank you all
speakers for a very interesting
presentation I will be very short one I
agree with majority of us were said
except two sins one that I from my point
of view we medical professionals have
some enough information how we should
communicate with patients more or less
maybe not enough as the communicative
actors but problem is in two parts first
that we have different methods for
treatment or acting in the pandemic
stage in different European countries it
was some kind different activities and
we reached the quite similar results and
this opening the the
possibilities for others to criticize
the different countries and use this as
this information but the most important
is that we're facing the
whoa
uh from this information born from
Russia from China another authoritarian
regime using the pandemic like the the
tulo instrument for that
and the reaction from buried centralized
forces they have their resources they
have the
people they have their teams and we try
to uh defend whether that's unrealized
way do you think that you should have
some something maybe in the Hera also to
to collect the information and prepare
and spread this information through the
all our society thank you very much
yeah thank you very much Anderson oh you
I know
thank you for these presentations we
actually learned quite a lot I have two
questions to ask Miss dmitra Dimitra
koplov and a comment to Mr Luca
we're talking about transparency and
Trust I during these uh reports I
want a
researchers to say if they're getting
um bursaries because the EU did Finance
some of this research Ms Dimitra
spoke about uh causes of your coveted
skepticism political
institutional Etc but I think that the
experience of people if they had if they
did get covered or if they had sex they
had side effects from the fourth
vaccine for example I think this sort of
thing does contribute to a lack of trust
in institutions and even doctors will
these studies aim to go further so to
collect the lived experiences of
patients
and also
question this problem with access to
information
because contracts are still not
accessible we are not we don't have
access to the text messages
and even the last videos on Pfizer where
there's these interrogations in Davos
those aren't accessible either
so I think this contributes to
um
doubt among citizens Mr Luca
I was also researching this information
I read Noam chomsky's book
about manufacturing concerns
and we had a book in France called the
new guard dogs from sarahimi who spoke
about how to fabricate information
and how to use it as a tool of War we
see China and Russia using these tools
is the European Union not also using
them in some way because during three
years we did have to deal with a lot of
measures limiting our freedom some
doctors for example were suspended in
France and they had to change their
their job we couldn't go to the cinema
from one they said next for example
there's a hunt on doctors in France if
they
prescribed certain treatments they were
called to task on that
so
this uh
code of this information created by the
EU did not also work as propaganda
didn't it also remove from us our right
of uh choosing and of speech now you
only have one minute I leave you to two
minutes no problem but don't over
um go over the two minutes please Mrs
Anderson
yeah thank you very much for your very
interesting uh presentation today and I
will have to say I'm quite speechless
from what I've heard today Mr clarksman
you said in the beginning you said we
should allow people to form their own
own opinion my question is this how will
people be able to form their own opinion
if everything any differing opinion is
they are carefully shielded from social
media being being censored I mean I'm
pretty sure you know about all of this
you let us listen to it to an audio and
I truly believe what we heard in that
audio it truly reflects on how people
feel about this issue uh I just have a
feeling rather than acknowledging that
governments did violate fundamental
rights that governments did undermine
democracy that governments did Silence
different opinions
I get the feeling you will use this to
educate governments on how to better
manipulate people the next time to get
them to do what they want them to do
pretty much frame them into compliance
um
the major take my takeaway from today is
is really this you do not see citizens
as responsible decision makers you see
citizens as stupid naughty irresponsible
children selfish on top of that that
need to be tricked into doing the right
thing and to be quite Frank I won't even
bother to ask a question because I'm
just sick and tired of having to listen
to your desperate attempts to pass off
as democracy and concern for public
health what in reality is utter contempt
for the people and the people really
deserve better than having to listen to
something like this and fund it on top
of it thank you thank you very much
I do want to repeat that we treat all
our experts with respect
I said I do want to repeat that we treat
all our experts and envites here with
respect
Mrs dimit a professor Dimitra coppolo
please you have the floor for your final
answers and then I come to Mr Lucas
thank you
um Mrs rivasi used the example of face
masks uh in the beginning of the
pandemic as an example
for people's lack of trust and indeed I
have also heard myself this example
being used as a reason for people not
feeling trustful
um
against all the other information that
they received
after that
um I'd like to add a few comments about
um the elimination of tweets this is an
example that Mrs rivasi mentioned
um as a way to control what kind of
information is posted and what I would
like to add is that these reductions are
always reactive information gets out it
gets flagged as fake the posts get on
social media get get down but people
have already been exposed to that
information so even if that gets
retracted we cannot control how people
will use
um uh or respond to that information so
again what I think we need to prioritize
and I think Mrs Anderson will agree with
me on that is that people need to become
part of the solutions that are being
designed and pushed forward the model of
having experts making decisions for the
public is not working anymore so we need
to prioritize the creation of inclusive
processes that allow the public to
become part of the conversations and
become part of these decisions because
people need to feel empowered to make
their own decisions so we need to make
them part of that process
so I very much agree with you Mrs
Anderson that people we need to treat
people as responsive decisions makers
and I my research and my study and my
personal opinions are definitely don't
imply that people need to be tricked
into something so although we cannot
control how our research or our the
science that we create is going to be
used what we need to make sure is that
we include people as part of that
process and we're not making decisions
on their behalf without even asking them
so I very much do believe in empowering
citizens just as responsive and decision
makers who are participating actively
and they're making active decisions to
um the different processes that are
being made whether the context that we
are exploring is public health or the
pandemic or any other context thank you
so much
thank you very much Professor for all
your answers Up Until the End
um and sharing your expertise with us
that was um really very interesting Mr
Lucas for your final answers and remarks
well I had no idea this is going to be
so exciting
um
point for you I would date to you Mrs
Anderson
vote
for politicians and we vote for taxes
that pay for a public health system if
you don't like it you can campaign
against it you can say let's make all
vaccines completely voluntary you can do
that and you can go to the voters and
you can say vote for me and we're going
to have completely different public
health system and they like it or they
don't like it they're very few or they
don't but the fact is we do have at the
moment in most Western countries a
strong consensus behind a public health
system which has some element of
coercion there are diseases which are so
dangerous that you will not be allowed
out on the streets and you will be
confined in a hospital against your will
multi-drug resistant tuberculosis being
perhaps one example that's what people
vote for don't like it campaign
differently
point I would make though in response to
what Mrs euron said and this is where
from your your country and my country
are very different from Russia and China
is that in Russia and China
nobody gets to vote
in any meaningful way so the public
health system you have in Russia and
China and all the information operations
that go with it do not have the
Democratic legitimacy that the public
health messaging in your country or my
country or this country or anywhere else
in the Democratic world do that's the
big difference so I don't agree that you
can put
um the information operations conducted
by Russia or China or Iran or North
Korea and say but look United States and
the European Union and France we do this
too because there's a difference there's
a democratic mandate in one system and
there's no Democratic mandate in the
other
um I was very um pleased to see my old
friend Mr Alexis yeah nice to see you
again and I reminded me that I I didn't
pick up the point that was made earlier
that I do think there's a strong overlap
between the anti-ukraine conspiracy
theories and the public health
conspiracy theories in each case there
is a real argument to be made you can
say I think NATO shouldn't exist anymore
you can say that completely honestly in
the people who believe that but there's
an overlap between the people who say
the war in Ukraine is the result of a
western plot of NATO expansion and
Russia is not to blame with people who
may also say that the whole covid
episode is a result of some huge plot
and you know karish Fab is trying to
take over the world so there is there
are conspiracy theories
um overlap in their in in one sense even
though they may be also autonomous in
another
I also just wanted to praise the work of
EU versus disinfo and particularly in
your country the debunking
um efforts the lithuanians of pioneered
are really effective rapid response to
rumors whether they're Public Health
rumors or national security rumors or
whatever where they nail very quickly
this comes from a instant which actually
never took place and they get the they
nail the LIE before it's really got its
its boots on and it's got into the
information sphere so we'll donate you
any for that and finally in response to
what umassi I literally said about one
minute before you started speaking I'm
not here to defend the government's
response and I do not think that any
government any decision maker any
scientist any journalist can say I got
this 100 100 right I literally said that
about a minute before you spoke so I
think that and I also said about five
minutes before you spoke
um the the disinformation is a lot of it
is endogenous and it goes in order
actions you have all sorts of people
saying all sorts of nonsense to all
sorts of other people that is the way a
free Society works I think there are
things we can do to make our information
system better and more resilient and to
work better in the service of our
democracy and I also think which I think
you did not address that I've argued
quite firmly and with plenty of evidence
that our democracies are under attack
from our geopolitical adversaries and we
have to think about it and it's not
enough to say well okay the mbb's saying
bad things but look these other people
are saying bad things too these other
people are not nuclear superpowers and
they are not trying to change the way
the world Works in a way that's going to
be very bad for you and for me and for
everyone in this room thank you very
much for having me
voila there you are thank you very much
um Mr Lucas as you can see the
appreciation
um of uh of this committee for um for
your expertise but also your friend
answers we like that in this committee
we don't have to agree on everything
absolutely not we come from different
political groups uh but we like the
frankness and your expertise so thank
you very much um for being here and
sharing that with us it's uh for sure
very helpful for the drafting of our
report and that and you can stay if you
want because we have a second session
and that I think is um is is is a is a
good compliment to the first um half of
uh of the hearing of today
um as you know this committee we have
all these hearings we have missions but
we also have studies
um and in the beginning of um uh the
work of this commission the members
based on the discussion we had in the
coordinators
um
asked for a study on on the impact of
this information misinformation and
propaganda
and that study is commissioned by The
Policy Department for economic
scientific and Quality of Life policies
a research branch of the DJI poll on the
effect of communication and this
information during the covid-19 pandemic
and we have two of the four authors
online with us today that is Professor
diers Lawson and Miss Jacob both of them
been working the other two authors are
Pierre hausmer and Adam zagrony Bosch
but I gladly give now I think first the
floor to Professor this Lawson and then
miss Jacob to present the study I think
that would be very interesting Professor
are you online
I I am
the floor is yours Professor thank you
my name is Audra diers Lawson and I'm a
professor of risk and crisis
communication at Christiania University
College in Oslo Norway and it is my
pleasure to be here to discuss the
challenge of communicating in the EU
throughout the covid-19 pandemic
the covid-19 pandemic is an example of a
societal Health crisis because it
disrupted all aspects of Our Lives
governments containment policies also
change the way that we worked consumed
and interacted at least in the short
term and potentially paved the way to
new behaviors policy and procedures
emerge emerging across domains of Social
and work activities next slide please
in this presentation I will provide a
summary of how we approach the analysis
of key academic and professional
research and in so doing I'll
demonstrate the very clear pattern of
effective and ineffective communication
with citizens emerging across the
countries I'll also discuss a practical
approach to building communication
strategy during major health crises
based on these best practices next slide
please
because of the truly Global nature of
the covid-19 pandemic it has created a
uniquely Rich set of insights into major
health crises accordingly there has been
an unprecedented amount of scientific
and professional research published on
it from around the world this
presentation summarizes 236 scientific
Publications and institutional reports
related to communication in the covid
pandemic between 2020 and 2022 and
including an exhaustive search for
English language resources on the 11
countries included nine as countries of
focus and two for countries of
comparison next slide please
this figure summarizes the six best
practices for communicating during the
pandemic identified by Scholars and
practitioners these past practices align
with the who's framework for risk
communication and Community engagement
they also demonstrate transferable
lessons for future health crises and
disasters so let's briefly talk about
the highlights from some of these
Lessons Learned
first effective pandemic communication
strategies should focus on explaining to
Citizens what self-protective behaviors
should be taken and why within each
country's National context
second research suggests that in the
pandemic
and then other major health crises
government should adopt a positive tone
supporting citizen confidence in taking
action
communicating engagement and also being
responsive because defensive messages
are simply less effective
third there is an overall citizen
preference for transparency and a
constructive management of fear and
anxiety
fourth in addition two-way communication
or citizen engagement was crucial in the
different countries relative
communication success governments this
means that governments must also listen
and respond to their citizens
communication needs
fifth it was also recognized that across
countries tailoring the messages to meet
different demographics the information
needs and attitudes about the coveted
and the self-protected behaviors was
essential for example the minority
communities within countries often
simply have different information or
communication needs
sixth finally regarding regardless of
the relative success in managing the
pandemic trust in the communicating
institutions is Central
if not the central feature of
communicating success
next slide please
in many ways we know how the covid-19
story has ended our job at this point is
to understand how we can collectively do
a better job to ensure that in future
health crises communication strategy is
developed and applied to improve health
outcomes and as it's been stated already
while no nation's response was perfect
many of the countries France Germany
Italy the Netherlands Portugal and
Sweden all demonstrated pretty
consistently good communication
practices
whereas there were significant
limitations or challenges in some cases
with identified in Bulgaria and Hungary
with Lithuania having some very good
practices as pointed out before and also
some challenges
simply those countries though with
comparatively poor communication
strategies experienced more deaths
during the covid-19 pandemic therefore
one measure of the success of the
communication effort should be based on
the evidence of lower death rates and
improved
where we can improve citizen adoption of
self-protected behaviors
next slide
overall the literature supporting and
analyzing the covid-19 communication
supports the need for an effective
stakeholder relation management
framework this framework focuses on the
interactions between the institutions
managing covid-19 citizen interests and
covid-19 related issues that lead to
self-protective behaviors being enacted
however it also recognizes that these
interactions occur within a complex
information environment comprising
multiple platforms certainly social
media traditional media and face-to-face
communication where there are often
contradictory messages and different
actors competing to capture citizen
attention and thus including the
disinformation and politicizing the
pandemic that this other speakers in the
previous session already addressed next
slide
research finds that issue-related
institutional Citizen and information
factors all affect message acceptance
this framework is really meant to be
used as a contingency approach to
building communication strategy what I
mean by contingency approach is that
agile crisis response using
research-informed message design and
evaluation is especially important in
complex situations like covid because it
allows governments and public health
authorities to diagnose key
communication challenges within a
community or a broader population and
then design messages to meet those
citizen information needs and this is
reflecting one of the best practices
that we've learned from covid-19
so let me summarize some of the key
findings from each of these factors with
regard to issue related factors across
the EU UK and U.S citizen knowledge of
their disease their own perception of
risks and the amount of control that
they feel like they have all affected
their willingness to take
self-protective behaviors issue-related
factors influence strategies in several
ways but let me give you an example
within the context of covid people were
already afraid so it just made more
sense to focus on building positive
messages about reducing risk rather than
fear-based messages in countries like
England and Hungary where fear-based
messaging or strategies emphasizing
punishment for non-compliance were
dominated in a lot of cases they had
lower demonstrated levels of Citizen
compliance with instructional messages
than those countries that focused on
positive ones
with regard to institution-related
factors now no matter whether we're
talking about research that was
analyzing High trust environments like
in Sweden or explaining like political
polarization eroded institutional trust
and that was correlated with low levels
of adoption of self-protected behaviors
in countries like the U.S the UK
bulbagarian Hungary
institutional trust emerged as Central
to Citizen behavior in short building
and maintaining a good reputation and
Trust especially related to health
issues is an essential tool for
governments and public health to
effectively manage future pandemics
with regard to Citizen behaviors citizen
related factors highlight the importance
of demographic and attitudinal
predispositions for people to enact
self-protective behaviors and
demographic factors matter depending on
location culture and timing there isn't
a single recipe for this but a more
Universal citizen factor is efficacy or
our confidence and our ability to enact
behaviors and our belief that those
behaviors lead to positive outcomes the
evidence from across the country's very
clearly concludes that as governments
and public health authorities they
should be communicating three key
messages one explaining what people
should be doing
second providing clear instructions on
how to perform the behavior correctly
and third providing evidence that there
is benefit for the people in performing
these behaviors and finally of course
information related factors popular
media and scientific research widely
recognized that coven 19's infodemic
poses a serious threat to persuading
citizens to adopt self-protected
behaviors the bottom line is that when
citizens feel like they don't have
enough quality information from their
governments and public health
authorities they will fill the perceived
information gaps by relying on other
sources of information opening the door
to myths and disinformation
but the other thing there are two other
factors affecting this in prolonged
crises several pieces of research
identified a newer challenge in
information fatigue this emerged across
countries like Germany Italy and
Lithuania people were simply tired of
hearing about covid in any way by the
end of it and finally where there are
lower levels of information literacy
that is being able to discern good
information from Bad citizens are more
likely to be resistant to adopting
self-protective behaviors that are
recommended
or even required by governments in
public health
next slide please
so while it is obvious to say that good
pandemic communication practice is
necessary good pandemic communication
practice requires planning adaptability
and a very strong connection to Citizens
and citizen attitudes
thank you for your time
thank you very much Professor
immediately give the floor to Mrs Jacob
foreign
oh we don't have any sound
can you hear me yes now we can hear you
thank you
good afternoon my name is Cecil Jacob
I'm a senior consultant at VBA Brazil
and it's my pleasure to present the
second component of this study
um focused on misinformation and
disinformation practices
um related to covid-19
and their counter measures in the EU
um next slide please
so I will first recall the methods we
use for this study to analyze this
information and misinformation practices
and then I will walk you through
um the different practices the key
themes of coverage information we
analyzed
um we also discussed about third
countries interference in this
information across the EU to conclude on
Contour measures and ways to improve
this counter measures next slides please
so for this study we also analyzed a
number of scientific Publications and
reports and for this section we focused
on nine EU member states which are
listed here
next slide please
um first of all I would like to give you
an overview of the concept of
disinformation and misinformation that
we describe in our study
um a first finding of our study is that
there is no shared definition on this
information
um although common aspects of defining
these two concept exists
um for example the ergas approach to
this information
combines the following elements so the
existence of false or misleading
information the intention to cause harm
or gain profits
and it often works with the assistance
of well-funded on automated technology
overall unlike misinformation this
information is characterized by the
presence of a deliberate intention to
cause harm
moving to the next slide
um desk research indicated that there
are seven types of disinformation
misinformation practices
um
that you can see on the screen for
example to illustrate in the context of
the covid-19 pandemic if we discuss
about manipulated content linked to this
information
we can mention a Blog that's manipulated
contact content of a scientific study
claiming that mRNA vaccine changed the
DNA of patients they were also
conspiracy theories from non-state
actors blaming social social groups and
certain ethnics minorities for spreading
the kovi 19 pandemic
when it comes to misinformation
practices we can mention a men's so a
small piece of videos tending to
exaggerate side effects of vaccine
therefore increasing mistrust in their
safety
we can also mention users of social
media platforms claiming that the kovin
19 couldn't be transmitted in hot and
humid climates
next slide please
um I would like to talk about the most
prevalent themes in covid-19
disinformation
and the largest share of force or
misleading information concerned
vaccination and immunization of about 24
followed by the severity of the kovi 19
government responses to covid-19 and
conspiracy theories surrounding the
pandemic
in this study we found that the spread
of such disinformation and
misinformation practices had an impact
on public opinion for instance according
to a UK study exposure to misinformation
was responsible for around the six
percent decrease in the intent of
vaccination
another study found that these practices
gave rise to
uncooperative Behavior among the general
population therefore undermining
compliance with the emergency measures
the next slide
um I will present another section of our
study in which we analyzed the role of
an impact of third countries in this
information across the EU
our study showed or rather confirmed
that Russia on China were the two-third
countries at the front line of covid-19
disinformation
uh we focused our research on the media
they used to spread this information as
well as the their different intentions
in both case Russia and China use Gene's
information for a geopolitical
advancements
um and
these
force or misleading foreign narratives
from the EU sides were monitored through
the use of the rapid alert systems again
this information
[Music]
um
to conclude although the overall impact
is difficult to Define and to quantify
um
it led EU citizens to question The
credibility of the EU and of also
National and Regional authorities
triggering official Health advice to be
ignored
in the next slide we will discuss the
counter measure taken
against these practices
so um the European commission called on
social media and platform to intensify
their role to counteract covid-19
disinformation by joining the 2018 kind
of practice and disinformation and
platform will also asked to publish
Baseline reports on their policies and
action to address covid-19
disinformation
at National level we analyzed emergency
measures tackling this information on
clothing 19 in nine member states
in some member states
plan were made or actually action were
taken to change legislation to
criminalize the dissemination of false
information it's worth mentioning that
Hungary was the only member states that
passed a law to counter disinformation
related to covid-19
um connected to that all member states
introduced restriction on freedom of
assembly except Sweden
and it's very important to to point that
as underlined by the Venice commission
limitation to the freedom of expression
must be kept to a minimum even in
emergencies Parliament parliamentary
control over restrictive measures must
be kept and all these restriction had an
impact on fundamental rights
the in the next slide I will present the
ways to improve this counter measures we
actually analyze the expected role of
the strength and code of practice and
disinformation together with the GSA
um as seen in this pandemic social media
and platforms were a key channel for
spreading this information surrounding
covid-19 and it further revealed the
shortcoming of the 2018 code of practice
on this information
this led
34 signatories to ratify the strength
and code of practice on this information
in June of this year which follows a
co-regulatory framework interning with
the GSA and aims to address the
shortcoming identified in this in the
previous code and further revealed with
the pandemic
beyond the EU code and the GSA we
recommend in our study
multistakeholder cooperation and further
coordination on a common transparency
reporting especially from the platform
side as well as further International
cooperation between third countries and
international organization
thank you very much for your attention
thank you very much to both speakers and
I immediately go to the political groups
for questions Mr kimperopolis please
and I would like to thank also
the uh the dear speeches for the very
comprehensive study
countering this information and
misinformation I mean send information
Overlord was a major test
for all institutions this information
spread by Foreign state sponsored
campaigns aimed at the fact that affect
our countries is forces to the pandemic
at the same time misinformation
proliferated through social media as
people were looking for answers the
fundamentally tried to amplify citizens
fear and undermine their trust a key
element in our fight against the
pandemic
the response from the EU and their
member states it was decisive with a
number of measures including the defense
Service Act increased transparency and
political advertising a strength and
code of practice on this information and
the mobilization of EU funds to include
citizens media literacy
and this Parliament
is at the is that the front end of these
efforts with the establishment of a
special committee on 40 interference in
non-democratic process in the Europe and
it will continue to do so
however the scientists will be with us
the years to come and we need to
continue equipping value with the right
tools to address them
we need a United and strategic approach
towards third actors meddling in
Europe's democracus
we need to work with diesel bedrooms to
address the roots of this information
and misinformation but also to empower
cities estimate informative decisions
through education digital and digital
literacy so I would like to know and to
ask you what are the measures
would you recommend in this regard thank
you very much
ah
uh thank you and Kathleen so many
colleagues today
um indicated that they are um medical
professionals by Education and Training
so I'm not uh but still I feel very
convenient in this committee but I would
feel even more convenient today if I
switch to my mother tank so I'm going to
continue in German and
um
have listened carefully to all of the
speakers today then the takeaway is
that communication is really one of the
greatest weapons that we have to fear so
I think if we've been talking about
communication and misinformation then
it's important to consider whether we
should be looking at the vaccination
issue again but I think the real dilemma
here which is something that was obvious
from the first speaker is and that I
failed to ask a question is like how can
we circumvent that so when we entered
into the high
alert phase where people needed to start
getting the vaccine
we had a problem but we had these
vaccinations that were safe but there
were nonetheless side effects
and and so the focus on the
communication
has to be really
worked out so we have all of these cases
where we're trying to do our homework
after the event there are certainly
things that we could improve on so I
think my real question is what are the
fears of politicians so I'm not thinking
about one particular party I'm just
thinking if you take a bird's eye view
what concerns did politicians have why
did they not want to apply some of the
suggestions were coming up with here why
didn't they want to go down the lines of
Greater transparency why didn't they
want to engage in more debate and I
think the reason is that this
vaccination campaign could not be as
successful
and the important thing was to save the
four million lives
we're living in a pluralistic society
and some people are idiots
so we have to think about how do we keep
them out of the debate or how do
politicians alternatively decide how to
be a bit more hesitant a bit more
restrained in their communication you
can't assume that everyone reads the
economies you can't assume that everyone
reads the Frankfurter algeminer title
and to show some newspapers are more
factual and more objective than others
we've seen it in this Parliament that
there are these narratives there are
alternative narratives alternative
realities that are presented and as
politicians then
I think they're was a desire not to
engage in this greater transparency that
we're now advocating they had to decide
what do we hold back or what
recommendations can we make
because we want to be better
equipped for any future pandemic and I
think that's what we're trying to
address here today thank you thank you
um it's not very easy now to see for we
For Whom the question is because it's
one study and so I'll give first the the
floor to Professor Deuce Larson and then
Mrs Jacob if you want to add something
you can of course do so and then the
other way around something like that Mrs
uh yeah this Lawson please
the I mean the two big questions that we
have from the speakers are what are
their measures and and also how do we
deal effectively with the challenging
communication environment and in some
ways the top line of the response to
this is that governments need to do a
better job in health institutions need
to do a better job of building long-term
institutional trust one of the things
that we see in sharp contrast is that in
institutional environments and this was
predictive in almost every country and
with vaccination uh research which I
work on it is it is predictive that if
people have trust in their institutions
they are much more willing to listen to
the information so this means that over
time governments and politicians
have to be more transparent we are
living in an age where the expectation
for communication engagement and direct
engagement is higher this is part of the
I think benefit of the social media age
we we speak a lot about the negative
sides of the the social media age but it
does mean that people expect and let me
give you an example of of a politician
who I think did an excellent job of this
was the first minister of Scotland
Nicholas sturgeon she was accessible
almost every single day for press
conferences her government also used
social media as a major means of
dissemination of information what they
did is is they had the same problems and
the same challenges of should we mask
should we not how to deal with
vaccination
but they created a dialogue on a daily
basis then this is also true in research
from Scandinavia which are high trust
environments it's not surprising that
lower trust environments failed to
communicate and fail to build the
conversation with with their citizens so
what can we do and how do we combat all
of this it's not the assumption that
people are are crazy or daft
people are looking out for their own
self-interests if if we can set aside
genuine anti-vaxxers for example for a
moment and only look at the vaccine
hesitant people are hesitant about
vaccines not because they're
anti-establishment but because they have
concerns and if they don't feel like
their concerns are being heard then
they're much less likely to to take that
leap of faith and especially if they
don't think that their institution is
trustworthy so there's both the
long-term
element of of making sure that we use
institutions of good health are of good
reputation now in some countries
um I believe Bulgaria was one of these
was where there wasn't great government
trust there was trust in the Health
Service and that was the case in a lot
of countries around the EU and around
the world was if there wasn't great
trust in the governments at least if
they have a function in health industry
and health sector they were trustworthy
so trying to identify what where their
trust deficits and deal with that is the
long term the short term is translating
the science much more effectively people
need to feel like they're being spoken
with not at and not trying to have
cover-up that's that's never going to
work especially in Crisis crisis is
about uncertainty
reduce uncertainty and you have people
who are much more likely to respond well
and to be more open to the the
recommendations
thank you very much Mrs Jacob
do you want to add
no you're muted again Mr Jacob
nope nope
nope
yes please uh Miss Jacob if the line on
the speak button is red that means that
we can hear you so I will do it now for
you
now it turns red it means that we can
hear you
thank you
perfect
um so I think my colleague responding
very
comprehensively to to the question from
the audience so I don't have anything
else to add
we'll come back to you later then
work
yes thank you very much
I also wanted to Echo the
congratulations and thanks that my
colleagues have already mentioned for
the study and the Very concrete nature
and comparative nature of the work
you've done the first question I wanted
to raise with you was to find out
whether you saw any kind of correlation
between the combat against
disinformation in some member states and
the rate of vaccination
you've gone that step further actually
you've shown correlation between
policies to combat
um disinformation and misinformation and
death rates from covert so I think that
you've reached that public health
requirement there so my secondary
observation and questions which which
are no less important relate to the uh
fear of uh police uh in countries where
disinformation has been penalized have
you seen
better rates of vaccination and then
fast checking
I wonder whether in countries or
situations where fast checking is
activated and present have you seen
a greater impact of
anti-disinformation policies thank you
thank you
merci yes thank you
I had a question to ask you I want to
know whether in
the world of disinformation and
misinformation state lies
where are we at I'm going to give you
the example that happened in Germany
where there was an inquiry carried out
by The Devout newspaper that showed
that the home affairs minister had used
in their Communications on covid
messages and figures which were alarmist
to sow fear and about lockdown and
encourage people to participate in
lockdown so what did they do they
reached out to researchers to get the
worst case scenario so they played about
with the death rate figures from covid
tinkered with those and said if the
government didn't take action then uh 70
of the population could be infected
there could be millions of deaths and
they went on repeating that
and that happened in March and April
2020.
so
for you is that a strategy which
makes it easier to accept the fact that
you have more coercive measures because
we had lockdowns we encouraged people to
get vaccinated Etc push them to do that
I think that we're talking about
disinformation
but who's done what at what level
so it was very criticized and I wanted
to know your opinion on that thank you
merci thank you today this kovi
committee is tasked with debating
um on disinformation but no social media
representative wanted to come and speak
to us and I'd like to thank the
secretary of state that wanted to come
and speak so disinformation
misinformation what is it it's an old
communication technique which tricks
public opinion to protect private uh
interests or otherwise and influence
public opinion now for a number of years
the commission has been funding
different studies into disinformation
and come up with a package in this too
but these Studies have stopped any kind
of debate any kind of questioning any
kind of opinions on these mandatory
experimentary experimental approaches
some examples we had Mrs small here who
said that vaccines had not been tested
in terms of their capacity to stop the
transmission of the virus before they
were launched on the market is that
disinformation Twitter file
there's this has been about the
moderation policy for contents and uh
social networks when it comes to covert
is that uh disinformation or
misinformation Bill Gates a video uh
said that Auntie
um covered vaccines are not effective
against all uh variants and they don't
stop you from Catching covert is that
disinformation a Veritas or um video
where uh Pfizer representative said that
uh covid would be a Scourge for a long
time and we were going to mute take
mutations so why don't we uh
if
and this all started in Wuhan is that
disinformation
the director of research and development
for strategy and scientific planning
um in Pfizer so it's an information bomb
about the manipulation of of covert
viruses which
hasn't been covered by the mainstream
media media apart from Twitter and you
can see that on any kind of video
sharing platform when uh Pfizer shared
this in January it didn't uh deny that
that employee had been working with them
and on virus engineering so
what
what who who sanctioned the publication
of these videos who has been regulating
this on Twitter and Tick Tock Etc
who decides whether this is
disinformation or not why uh is Pfizer
avoiding these questions is that
disinformation who decides fundamentally
on the official narrative on this who
decides Brussels or big Pharma for three
years now doctors and virologists have
been censored when they've dared to talk
about alternatives to injections
Etc and the effects that these could
have on women and young people so
the victims of the side effects uh our
total thousands and thousands of people
so when we're talking about
disinformation I think that using this
tool for our own propaganda their own
propaganda uh is of service to uh big
Pharma yes you had three minutes
um okay I don't know uh whether the
authors of this excellent study are able
to um to sort of make a yes or no on uh
this information so
um I will start with Mrs Jacob and and
please answer what you can answer of the
questions
um Mrs Jake
thank you
um so although we didn't analyze uh
whether the member states
in which legislation was passed to
criminalized
um this information
had an impact on the vaccination rate we
can say for sure that
um
any legislation
that
tried to regulate this information in a
very vague and non-specific language
can also restrict access to information
and prevent citizens from formulating
their own opinions
so
this could
suggest that
the vaccination rate wouldn't be higher
in this case
this is a professor at this Lawson can
you add something please
yeah there's the two questions about
silencing descent and what constitutes
disinformation and then the fear
question I think the the biggest risk in
silencing descent whether that's on
social media or anywhere else versus
directly confronting it is actually you
create the environment for missing
disinformation to grow
so I actually think it is quite
unhealthy and impractical because there
are no ways to to genuinely silence the
dissent and to silence concerns but what
organizations can do institutions
governments can do is when they try and
quelch the debate
it they do so out of a fear that it will
confuse people but I think that this is
this is underestimating people's ability
to understand information and to make
reasonable rational decisions for
themselves
so rather than silence debate there's a
communication Theory called inoculation
Theory and just like ironically talking
about vaccines you do two-sided
argumentation you give a little bit an
affair accounting of the opposition and
then you respond to it this I think is a
far better approach and especially in
conditions of uncertainty than it is to
truly silence the dissent so my caution
as a communication scholar is that you
will only
create the conditions for more desire
for the the banned information or
silenced information by doing so and
actually that dovetails well into the
fear issue
fear in and of itself is already going
to be there in in the pandemic and so uh
with the gentleman's example of Germany
my example of English approach which was
to amplify fear we actually see that it
had a
a genuinely damaging effect in terms of
self-protective behavior compliance
whether that is with vaccination or
whether it is face masking or or
anything else that when the two
strategies of amplifying fear and also
forced compliance are used you will have
people who if they feel like they have
to obey the letter of the law they will
but they won't end up learning anything
about transmission you know one of the
side effects of of the covid pandemic is
actually there's significantly lower
levels of of stomach related dysentery
kinds of issues in hospitals
um now because people are simply
practicing better hygiene so this is why
the three recommendations for good
communication practice which all centers
around a positive message is keep people
informed as much as there is and this
was a changeable environment being
honest about what we know and what we
don't know is part of the the challenge
providing people with concrete
recommendations for their behavior and
also and demonstrating how to do the
behaviors correctly but providing the
best possible evidence for for the
effectiveness of those behaviors those
are the really the best ways to address
it so if you combine that with the
two-sided the inoculation approach you
recognize people's fears you legitimize
their concerns and then you give as the
best information at any point it may
change and then you talk about The
Narrative of We Now understand more
about the disease and that's in places
where there is good communication
success that's exactly what they did
thank you very much for that clear
answer
um Mrs de la pizza please
thank you could we have a microphone
please
thank you very much for coming today
now you talked about the need to improve
confidence in the institutions well
perhaps first of all we need to address
the lack of confidence that's been
created how can we do that but it seems
to us that a critical mind isn't
necessarily a feature of those who are
in charge politically during the crisis
a political level that's not obvious
there have been attacks on Democracy in
my country there have been
Declarations of a state of alert
we're not seeing anyone asking for
forgiveness no one apologizing so I
think
we need to be aware that there was this
additional power and vulnerable
the citizens felt very much affected
they felt that Liberties were being
taken away and health is an excellent
pretext for doing that and now we have
the who
and its decision making
power which has been compromised by the
interests of financial Giants
and Europe is still giving greater
sovereignty in decision making to those
who are financially powerful thank you
thank you very much Mrs cerdas please
thanks Catelyn thank you to both
speakers for uh your input and your
presentation on the on the study and uh
many questions have been asked now and I
would like to reflect on why or on one
of the reasons why Portugal had such a
success on vaccines and on vaccination
rates against covid-19 digits to to
societal memory as uh 50 years ago
vaccines were not available widely and
people still remember nowadays what it
is like to perish from rubella
diphtheria measles and even polio to
have their kids paralyzed or even have
difficulties uh breeding I have a
concrete question for Professor diers
Lawson uh use explain uh that one of the
measures we can have to counteract this
is to reduce uncertainty but how can we
reduce uncertainty uh when we are facing
a very scientific fast Dynamic event
such as a pandemic such as it was in
covid-19 at the beginning mosques were
not appropriate then we were holding the
mass for those that really were on the
Frontline health professionals then it
was
um it was uh evidence that Mars helped
so this whole Dynamics how can we reduce
uncertainty when we have a fast-paced
information and uh you also say that one
of the the your suggestions is not to
Simon's The Descent but also to counter
explain so I'll try here uh to also
share that vaccines were deemed safe and
effective to avoid death or severe
disease for an individual unfortunately
there was hope for heart immunity which
did not matter realize it also does not
materialize for instance for the tetanus
vaccine to give an example and for us to
have a better understanding that this
can apply to some vaccines and not sun
on others we might have here in this
committee questions about how the
contracts for vaccines were made the
prices the doses but on safety I think
we have been a very well enlightened by
the health authorities about the safety
profiles of these vaccines
thank you very much espalus
thank you Kathleen and thank you for
being here and for presenting us the
study as my colleagues have already
elaborated on a lot of things I would
like to learn whether in your study you
have also looked at the problem of false
balance because that is the other side
of
um leaving an open space for differing
opinions for
um uncomfortable questions for adults
for critical interventions because I
know that the media love to have one
person from each side but unfortunately
if you have like 100 people who say the
vaccines work and one person who says it
doesn't then it might not be the best
idea to have them both in the same show
in presenting it at a 50 50
as a 50 50 issue therefore I would like
to know did you also look at this in
your study thanks
thank you very much and finally Mrs
Anderson I don't have anybody else on my
list Mrs Sanderson please
yes uh thank you very much for this very
interesting uh study and I'm really glad
that I'm actually here and listening to
you because
um I will have to tell you this study
comes across as something entirely
different than what you probably
intended uh with the study
um I would just like to point out on
page 21 under number three you write
provide evidence that there is benefit
so you're asking the governments to
provide a benefit that there is evidence
that there is benefit
um to what they want the people to do
but see that is exactly the problem they
did not provide any evidence they
immediately uh went on with threatening
people publicly shaming them ostracizing
them uh threatening them they would have
to pay for that for their treatment
themselves and and all of these things
and then I found it interesting that on
um page 20
um you did mention countries that used
fear-based messaging or emphasized
punishment for non-compliance had lower
levels of compliance and I do get from
that and from from what I heard here
today uh that you do not agree with
tactics like that but yet on page 18 you
talk about or
pretty much praised Germany for having
had good communication practices and I
really wonder and any German reading
this study they will take it it just
adds insult to injury did you not know
what the German government did with the
people did you not know that they
ostracized them publicly shamed them
they told them you wouldn't no longer
have a job if you don't get vaccinated
they told them you will have to pay for
your treatment yourself if you don't get
vaccinated I mean how can you write that
in your study and I do see that you had
good intentions so my question is
what actually was the goal of that study
and are you at all concerned about that
your study contributes to the
government's knowledge to more
effectively undermine democracy and more
defectively violate fundamental rights
thank you
that concludes uh all the questions that
we have from our committee Professor
Dias Larson can I give you the floor
please
sure and and let me let me frame the the
first the overall response is that
the when we're talking about good and
bad examples of communication and Ms
Anderson is is right to point out that
we my general recommendation is that
negative messaging is not particularly
effective however I would Point her to
page 17 where we clarify based on the
research that had been done German
Germany's particular strengths or the
digitization of information and cohesive
instructive communication now what
hasn't been LED and keep in mind that
this was a literature based review
um so to the extent about public shame
that hasn't been explored yet in the
literature
So based on my analysis of it in where
that was and also in my own research of
it
where that has been true in say the UK
particularly in England it's not
particularly effective
and so this is where some of the
conversations and some of the challenges
that I know already exist in Germany
probably come from is you have some very
good examples of communication practice
backed up with problematic policy I
won't play go into the politics of it
the intention of the study was to
summarize and reflect on what has been
empirically demonstrated to be useful
and unuseful and so in that case when we
look at some of the other questions and
comments the question about false
balance while this particular study did
not look at the journalism
I would generally concur with the the
ladies response with the is indeed false
balance isn't helpful because it creates
the illusion that all sides are equal
and it gives equal air time without a
critical response and in some ways the
the media's love of false false balance
I think does create additional problems
in terms of how do you present
information in a way that is both fair
and also in a way that acknowledges
where their strengths and where their
weaknesses and that is in fact what
we've tried to do so when we come to
some of the strengths of countries when
we look at digitization or in Portugal's
case certainly institutional history has
been is probably a good accounting but
what the other things that they did that
were particularly strong were
cross-platform and instructive
communication and I think that this is I
hope that this is what has come across
quite clearly in that portion is that
the best communication strategies focus
on the positive ones and whether the
politicians are the best suited for
presenting the information or whether
it's public health that is best suited
at presenting the information what's
absolutely essential is that it is done
in a way that deals with the best
information at a time so yes the
uncertainty is going to be there in a
fast-moving Health crisis and especially
in something like covid for example
where we didn't know what was going on
at a lot of different points so you I
would go back to the example of the
first minister of Scotland who
maintained the daily communication
effort to narrate and explain what was
changing why it was changing it and then
bring in health experts too to very
directly say here's why our thinking on
this has changed
people will be willing to go with it if
they feel that they're being
communicated with honestly and as adults
and and for the democratization of
issues this is where many countries fell
down as I said at the beginning no
country got it absolutely right
there are things that we can learn and
replicate and there are things that we
should avoid and so we should avoid
negativity
fear compliance where possible and we
should emphasize self-efficacy and
strength of response
thank you very much MRSA Jacob do you
want to add something or
no thank you my colleaguants are very
precisely okay she does doesn't she
um can I can I um
um well thank both authors um and and
speakers um I think it was excellent and
I invite all of us to have a close look
to the to the study as well as as for
other studies that we shoot um and I'm
not going to make conclusions that's all
almost always impossible uh but there is
some similarity well there's a lot of
similarity between the first part and
the second part
um and and I think they were very good
in in keeping a balance but both Mr
Lucas as Mrs Audra Diaz Lawson said
something that is extremely important
for us this is not a committee that will
judge the different measures that has
been taken by national governments and
and nobody is 100 right because this
pandemic um It All Happened uh to us and
it was doing by learning and it's our
task to do the lessons learned and um
and that goes for uh misinformation and
disinformation as well so
um thank you very much to everybody who
participated in this afternoon's uh
hearing again very important things that
we've learned that we will put in our
reports that are the lessons learned to
be more prepared for the next pandemic
at the European level that let that be
the main task of this committee thank
you very much and I see you all tomorrow
nine o'clock thank you very much have a
nice evening